in the world to my hero academia nearly
80% of the population have inborn
superpowers called quirks these
superpowers run the gamut from the
standard to the completely bizarre but
not all quirks are created equal
here are the worst and best quirks
ranked minoo rumen naita
has the ability to throw giant sticky
balls that grow on his head in place of
hair the balls stick to whatever surface
they land on but Manasseh himself
bounces right off already were off to a
bad start
the idea of throwing sticky balls that
grow out of your scalp is incredibly
disturbing the worst part however is the
side effect that comes with throwing too
many of his hair balls
if Manasseh over uses his quirk his head
starts to bleed which implies that his
balls are closer in composition to skin
and hair all in all it's a deeply
disturbing quirk that's gross enough to
offset even the faintest possibility of
usefulness it might seem strange for a
quark with so few downsides to land on
the tail end of this list but by the
same token mocchi broooo Jiro's quark
has no upsides either it's just a tail
in fairness it's a tail that he has
enough control over to whip around and
smack villains with however compared to
the most powerful and most bizarre
quirks in my hero academia his
superpower is just boring in fact the
plainness of his quark is about as much
character so Jiro gets when your entire
personality is rooted in how boring your
superpower is that's when you know
you've lost the genetic lottery still
there's no need to live life with your
tail between your legs
Mariota gada is one of the most
impressive heroes in my hero academia
trained by the pro hero knight i and
considered one of the big three at UA
miryo seems to be the Platonic ideal of
an all might successfully he does it all
with a quirk that's much worse than he
makes it look with his permeation quirk
myrio can be completely intangible when
he becomes tangible inside of a solid
object he's rocketed out of that object
at high speed you might be wondering why
such a useful power comes solo on the
list
the reason is simple myrio goes blind
deaf and loses the ability to breathe
when he faces basically the only thing
he feels is a vague sense of falling
which combined with his tendency to face
into the ground sounds like pure torture
spinners quirk lets him stick to walls
but that's because he's basically a
lizard
man in a world where kids have naval
lasers and sugar powered super strength
the ability to look like a big lizard
just seems sad some of the other
characters have inherited animal
features but they also get cool powers
of their own toko Yami has a bird head
but he also has a shadow creature that
can fly him around Kota has a rock head
but he can talk to animals even another
mutant suyu has a long tongue acid vomit
and can camouflage herself with her
surroundings compared to any of those
spinners ability to look like the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle original
character that you drew when you were a
teenager just doesn't measure up the
world of MHA is full of high-tech
gadgets and weird technology that heroes
and villains can use if they weren't
lucky enough to be blessed with an
exceptionally useful work of course
someone has to design those interesting
gadgets and weapons which is where may
hat su-mei comes in she attends UA to
learn how to make support equipment MHA
is in universe term for utility belts
costumes and super weapons it's no
surprise that had su Mays focuses on the
support side of things since her quirk
is pretty boring at zoom a zoom quirk
lets her vision zoom in any object that
she's looking at up to five kilometers
away it's not a bad quirk but it's not
really a good one either though under
hats who may chose a career path that
out almost nothing to do with it
even in his old age Gran Torino has
proved himself to be a powerful
combatant multiple times and his jet
pork seems to be a major factor it
allows him to shoot air from the soles
of his feet giving him incredible speed
and agility as he dashes around that
delivers high-velocity punches so why
isn't he higher on the list as it turns
out that speed has to come from
somewhere
gran torino zkk work suits air out of
his feet but it's the same air he uses
to breathe that's some incredible lung
strength but it means that there's a
hard limit to how often and how much he
can use his quirk still you could say
that his quirk is a breath of fresh air
compared to the more outlandish ones out
there chotto Izawa AKA Eraserhead can
temporarily halt the activation of
courts as long as he keeps his eyes open
after looking at a quirk user as soon as
he blinks the effect ends it doesn't
effect mutant types like spinner or gyro
but it would stop Todoroki from
controlling fire and ice that's a pretty
useful power in the world of my hero
academia which is packed to the brim
with pork users of all types the ability
to shut
down a villain before they start doing
their villainous acts is solid but
that's all it does ultimately a quirk
that depends so much on the presence of
other quark users to be effective makes
this a middle-of-the-road power who
among us can say that they've never
stomped through sand castles or
miniature cities pretending to breathe
nuclear fire while humming Blue Oyster
Cult second best song it's an enticing
fantasy and one that superhero mount
lady can live every day as you might
expect from her funny name mount lady
can grow to giant size with her gigantic
vacation quark unfortunately it's only
half as useful as it sounds
mount lady can grow to giant size but
she doesn't have the ability to grow and
shrink she only has the ability to grow
to her giant size and back to regular
human size that seems like a recipe for
disaster in metropolitan areas and the
lack of control means that Giganta
fication is unlikely to land in the top
spots of any most desired superpower
list still we'd be lying if we said that
we didn't want to act out our own Tom
Hanks in big fantasies
we already have at least one super
speedster in the my hero academia cast
in the form of you a student Tania EDA
but his engine quark is still revving up
in the anime instead his brother the pro
hero Ingenium has a much more powerful
quark at the moment instead of powerful
engines on his legs like his younger
brother and Jean iam has engines on his
arms letting him blast through the air
like the world's fastest Naruto runner
in other words he's both fast and
furious I live my life a quarter mile at
a time in the world of my hero academia
quirks usually come with a drawback or
weakness but that's not something
Choteau Todoroki has to worry about his
quirk allows him to control fire and ice
to an almost unlimited extent on the
right side of his body he generates ice
while on the left he can control fire
granted over using one half of his body
reflects that increase or decrease in
temperature onto his own body but just
switching to the other half regulates
his own temperature back to normal even
in the world of my hero academia Totoro
keys quark is absolutely powerful in
fact its existence is explicitly due to
active effort on his father's part to
engineer an ultra-powerful heir however
putting Totoro keys tragic superhero
origins side where he can't find any
particular issue with this ultra
powerful work we're not gonna play hot
and cold here this work is worth getting
fired up about copycat characters have
existed in superhero fiction almost as
long as superpowers from taskmaster to
Amazo there's just something innately
satisfying about seeing someone copy and
combine familiar superpowers in new ways
since my hero academia never shied away
from a good superhero fictional trope
there is of course a copycat port
wielder the catch is that he's pretty
undeniably heroic even if he's kind of a
jerk about it NATO manoa is a UA student
with the ability to copy the quirk of
anyone he touches he can copy up to four
abilities and use any one ability at a
time for up to ten minutes before he
needs to physically touch them again
well that's not much use out in the real
world manoah's copycat quirk is
extraordinarily useful in the court
filled world of my hero academia being
able to copy up the four powers at a
time with a touch makes manova an
incredibly dangerous opponent in a melee
what's more knowledge of his quirk only
makes him more dangerous since he can
throw in pull-ups to confuse clever
enemies
the only real drawback to his work
besides the time limit is that he can
only make use of quirks that don't
depend on external power sources fat
gums fat absorption quark wouldn't be
possible for the skinny manova and so on
a balanced diet is important to living
your best life for Tamaki Amagi key a
balanced diet is particularly important
to living his best superhero life as the
hero sun-eater Tamaki has the ability to
manifest characteristics of whatever he
eats as part of his own body that means
that if he eats clams or octopus he can
turn parts of his body into tentacles or
clam shells if he eats a bird he can
grow wings and fly the size number of
manifestations and exact features of the
food he wants to use are entirely up to
him while it's an incredibly
weird-looking quirk to have it's
undeniably a useful one hit up and all
you can eat fish buffet and you can
probably swim faster than Michael Phelps
eat a few plates of chicken and you can
kind of halfway fly and hop around you
get the idea
Tamaki's power isn't even limited to
conventional food either at one point he
eats some crystals created by another
quirk user in order to make his own
flesh into crystals best genius fiber
master quirk allows him to control
individual threads of fiber that makes
him nearly unstoppable against anyone
wearing clothes which is nearly everyone
he's in never-nude is that exactly what
it sounds like Tobias suffered a rare
psychological affliction of never being
able to be completely naked best genus
has some minor drawbacks to his quirk
for one the type of thread influences
how easily he's able to control it still
it's one of the weirdest and most useful
courts and all of the my hero academia
universe unless he goes up against a
super villainous nudist colony best
genus tis one of the best twice can make
an exact duplicate of anything as long
as he knows the exact measurements he's
limited to two doubles at a time and
those doubles are slightly weaker than
the real things but they still have
their own abilities in will that means
that functionally he doesn't have any
limits when it comes to cloning himself
he can clone himself and then that clone
can clone himself and then that clones
clone can clone himself and so on
infinitely beyond its use in making
personal armies it's the perfect
cooperative work with other villains
since twice can make a clone of himself
and a clone of another villain which can
likewise repeat seemingly infinitely and
back the only real reason
my hero academia isn't entirely about
the world's heroes uniting against this
seemingly ultra powerful villain is that
twice spends most of his time completely
insane as a result of cloning himself
too much he doesn't know if he was the
original clone and spent years worrying
that he was just his own doppelganger as
horrifying as that might be there's a
pretty easy solution just write numbers
on all your clones heads and it doesn't
seem like identity confusion will ever
be a problem they look exactly like us
so in order to avoid confusion I'm gonna
mark us each with a red X right now
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite anime are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]